yo this video is sponsored by
Squarespace make your next move what's
up my well-read Ballas this week we
taking things to the Mex
with where the wild things are buy my
rescinding
it's gettin hella late up at the crib
and instead of catching some Z's little
shorty Max is sporting some fly-ass
whoop threads and hopping around like a
bunny old bad sauce we see him pitch
intense chasing a dog with a fork we're
just making a damn mess instead of
calling the Exorcist Max's mama all like
chill you wild thing
matter of fact you better hustle your
crazy ass up to bed cuz you ain't
getting no dinner tonight
damn girl a growing boy needs his grub
max roll up to his room pissed as hell
when Oh a bunch of trees start growing
in his room and a damn ocean tumbles by
sounds like this little Dubin growing a
different kind of tree man I mean so boy
hop on the fly has boat and start
flowing down the ocean for nearly a year
finally max landing his funk bout spot
where a bunch of busted ass beasts
called wild things be chillin when he's
big-headed [ __ ] see max they wig out
and try to make him all scared man it's
like Sesame Street on a bad shrimp but
Max is a hard-ass gangster who don't
back down
we stars mad-dogging them in hollows
tail [ __ ] and boom they all put that
hustler side and slow their road damn
this little player got some big-boy
balls Tony I have to see how real max be
come up and look at Moto's give him a
bad clown and make him king of all wild
things to celebrate this ball of status
max throws a bangin rumpus oh yeah hey
max ela screw arrangement of the moon
when out of nowhere
max hollers stop and says them Buster's
to bid with no supper even though he's
rockin a crown like a G now this little
brush starting to feel man lonely he
just want to be at the spot where
somebody loves him the most
basically he misses his mama max gets
the munchies and decides to head home
but the wild things all like don't leave
us player but Max be are like too late
and throws up the deuce back at the crib
max finds his hot dinner still on the
table
just
for him to get his grub on sounds like
soul food to me I love you mama
when it comes to the children's league
gang this book right here broke all
kinda rules
see most kids books reppin childhood is
just sipping on juice boxes and playing
a little grab-ass but this book right
here explore the dark it goes down
inside the minds little kids cuz I'm a
real it ain't always all good when
you're a kid you got to deal with some
real raw emotion that faraway land of
wild things represents the psychology of
a young blood dealing with the booty
load of mixed up emotions this hood
serves as a spot where max can recognize
all this confusion and anger work
through it and understand what's really
important in his life at first Max's all
geeked up to chill with the wild things
cuz with them he can live out his
beastly side without having his pain or
as momma always try to control him but
when he gettin crunk up at the rumpus he
recognized that even getting lit and
gonna make him happy so when he kills
the party by screaming now stop he shows
that he got more control over his anger
you can almost hit his balls drop a
little bit and at the end of the story
little max recognized that is ma man
controlling him just to be a [ __ ] nah
blood she just really cares about that
hot grub at the end reppin the fact that
no matter how much he acted like a he'll
always have the unconditional love of
his mom look the world is a messed up
place even for children but instead of
just sweeping it under the rug kids can
use their imagination to beast through
all that loneliness and isolation like
syntax a there are games children must
conjure up to combat an awful fact of
childhood the fact of their
vulnerability to fear anger hate
frustration all the emotions through
fantasy max the hero of my book
discharges his anger against his mother
and returns to the real world sleepy
hungry and that peace with himself yo
thanks for kicking the with you boy man
hey go thanks for kicking it with me and
if you're looking to build a fly website
to show up your skills start an online
business I just share your ideas and
creations head on over to Squarespace
comm slash Thunder Squarespace has got
easy-to-use tools for you to quickly and
easily make the website you want and
they've got tons of award-winning fly
templates to help you get started you
don't need to know coding or anything
and they're giving all ul red ball is
10% off your first order when you use
the offer code thug notes if that ain't
good enough Squarespace is hook you up
with a free 14-day trial so you can see
for yourself just how easy it is so go
to squarespace.com slash thug notes or
use the link in the description below to
sign up today and you'll get a free 14
day trial to test it out be sure to use
the offer code bug notes to get 10% off
your order thanks to Squarespace for
being a homie and sponsoring this video
and we've got lots more videos on the
way so click here to go to our channel
page and if you haven't already make
sure to subscribe while you're there
catch y'all next time peace